when you went and you got deployed what
was exactly what you expected it to be
what was different
interesting question so i
the the relief of because you've trained
so much and you prepared so much for
this but you really don't know until you
go out there and do it if you're going
to perform um so that little part that
little megan question in the back of
your head
and i didn't anticipate what it would
feel like to go out and do those first
missions what that would what that would
feel like internally i know i would go
out do the mechanics of it but it was
this sense of relief that i have been
tested in combat and i was not found
wanting i did not let the guys down to
my right and left and that was this
feeling of relief for me anyway i don't
really know for uh for anybody else but
i had this sense of relief like okay it
wasn't just training it wasn't just
thing i aspired to i have now done it
and now i'm building on this foundation
adding experience to that training and
then i continue to add that experience
continue to learn from both mistakes and
failures going forward so it's uh it's
all about adapting as you know both in
in life and on the battlefield no matter
what you're doing but uh but that was
that was the sense of relief i think
that was most surprising to me did you
have any shock factor was there any
shock factor to you where you know like
uh let's uh
a pitcher okay pitcher plays for high
school then maybe goes and plays a
triple a and then hey he gets called up
you're going to come and pitch first
game is going to be
in st louis cardinals you know you come
out oh my gosh 60 000 people and then
you get up there and you're looking at
the guy you know mike trouts up and
whoever is up you know it's the
different leagues and you're like okay i
got to pitch this guy the booing you
know maybe the the speed you know they
say from college football to nfl speed
everything's faster what was what was
the shock factor for you was there
anything when you got deployed where you
said
nobody prepared me for this was there
anything
i think the confusion of how hard it was
to tell
where the enemy is where the bullets are
coming from where the mortars are coming
from where the rpgs are coming in from
in the chaos of combat in particular uh
the campaign for ninjaf which was a
two-week campaign in iraq to retake the
city from the jaish amadi militia in
august of 2004. and it was just chaos
and it was like what i had seen on those
world war ii movies i watched with my
dad uh where just there's bullets flying
everywhere it's an urban environment and
uh you're kind of not really sure you're
hearing these tracks and you're and
you're just not sure exactly where's
what's going on because you're getting
these bradleys by these fighting
vehicles and they move around these
tracked vehicles so you're kind of
discombobulated uh things are exploding
everywhere you're moving in and then the
back drops down and you run out into the
fight and uh it's kind of like getting
your bearings is a little bit uh
discombobulating i guess
one scene you know the opening scene of
saving private ryan where they opened it
up bam is it did you have an experience
like that when you went out there where
was sudden
i think that that experience of the
bradley fighting vehicle having that
ramp go down in the middle of a
firefight he's dropping you off because
you don't really know you're not
as a sniper in the back or as assault
team leader in the back you're not
really in communication with uh with the
guys that are driving and even if you
were you wouldn't be exactly short it
looked like the math study that you did
and all of a sudden boom you're out
there and it's time to go so uh that
would be the most similar but i don't
think it's anything
yeah could ever be like with those guys
experienced uh going over the beaches at
normandy that's just a whole another
level i mean you're going in to a place
where the enemy is entrenched the enemy
has the high ground they have they have
pretty much all the advantages and
you're running across open space to try
to get up to that high ground when they
have machine guns in place up there
that's that's back when it was hard so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye